the entire crypto world is collapsing  right now FTS was one of the largest  exchanges in the world it was founded by  Sam Beckman freed a crypto billionaire  at just 30 years old but recently people  started withdrawing their money from FTX  but FTX didn't have enough money to go  around it was a classic Bank Run and if  FTX didn't somehow get their hands on  some emergency cash to hand out to  customers it would implode so they  reached out to their rival binance  desperate for a bailouts only for  binance to back out last minute hinting  that FTX had mishandled customers money  so just like that FTS lost 90 of its  value investors who didn't pull their  money out in time are out of luck and  this is taking the whole crypto Market  down with it subscribe to find out what  happens next